[Musik]
gut sie miteinander für einige immer
zusammen unterwegs haben sie fast als
sternstunde jahr 2007 und acht findet
themen als eigentlich jedem jahr am
meisten beschäftigen wenn es um die
hände und füße ganz persönlichen staat
stunden 14 jahren das möchten wir heute
im kosmos der mieter vor zürich bevor
man das möchte nun an bord momente aus
der union
[Musik]
neben wir wirklich das leben das ihr
leben wollen herzlich willkommen breslau
vielen dank herzlich willkommen ergo
danke in den letzten wochen neue damen
und herren wurde gestrickt was das zeug
hält um diese tussi herz zu produzieren
wir können nicht irgendwie rum schreiben
als würden wir gemütlich sagen wir mal
1870 irgendwie auf dem sofa sitzen mit
vielen project ja ich finde wir wundern
uns eigentlich viel zu wenig über das
wunderwerk das wir sind in körper und
geist
wir verstehen unser universum bis eine
sekunde nach dem urknall
aber da stecken wir fest eine geschichte
kreieren heißt mannschaft ein universum
ich kann sie jetzt hier anfassen sie
sind mein dialogpartner sie sind
wirklich der welt als solche eine
gerechtigkeit zu attestieren dass das
vermag ich nicht ich sage freiheit ist
wichtiger als alles andere das alles um
den islam herum lässt mich nicht kalt
sondern das bewegt mich existenziell
ich will mich in den logen ich habe eben
auch diesen defekt und ich kann einfach
alles mal die schweiz als unter gehendes
römisches reich
das nehmen wir leider gottes schluss
motto unseres brechen ganz ganz
herzlichen dank für dieses gespräch
nicht regnen hier studiert dann machen
wir schluss
[Musik]
ebenso schöne durch handel kommt das
bücherfest um liegen dass james key die
gerne durch preiswerte leben ja einsatz
vor dem jahr wo man neben dem kopf gott
ist vor der 88 jährige ungarische
philosophin agnes heller der sich seit
der sinn des lebens ist es zu leben wenn
sie auf ihr bewegtes leben zurück
schauen sehen sie darin einen sinn was
ist sinn sehen das leben selbst ist sinn
sinn des lebens ist zu leben
und natürlich habe ist ein hat mein
leben einen sinn von dem standpunkt aus
wo ich jetzt bin ausgesprochen immer
wieder müssen druck dann kann nämlich
gespräch mit dem jakob kern wofür tun
und nahrungsmittel abgab in syrien
koordiniert display war eigentlich ganz
simpel und auch bitter nötig was
erwarten sie von menschen die mir die
hier in sicheren im trockenen sitzen
ich glaube das wichtigste ist dass sie
nicht vergessen dass sie nicht vergessen
dass aleppo passiert ist dass das syrien
immer noch zerstört ist
das schulden wir den syrern dass wir sie
in unseren gedanken behalten und dass
wir mit leiden wenn bild wie die leute
in aleppo besonders berührt hat mich ein
muss sagt von deutscher philosoph gert
scobel wo sieht einige jahre jahrzehnt
meditiert und da seid meditation ist wie
ein vorbereitungs stärker verloren was
sich ändert glaube ich ist unsere
einstellung dazu wenn man wenn man die
erfahrung machen kann dass man jetzt
sehr bildhaft gesagt vorher schon weg
sein kann und dass dieses weg sein
können oder weg sein ein ganz normaler
zustand der wirklichkeit ist dann hat
man vielleicht vielleicht auch nicht
weniger angst nichts bezahlt stück
sprüche dem ich wahrscheinlich mit dem
charles foster wird erhält bleibt ihnen
das wie einen fuchs wie einen hirsch und
alwine notter wo bislang als ob da
ziemlich ohne ablenkende um am leben zu
bleiben müssen sie unmengen fressen für
mich würde das bedeuten einen bigmac
alle vier minuten kommen ja der
überraschend steht momentan völlig hat
der witzigsten momente erlebt mit dem
pop philosoph richard david precht und
dann ganz zum schluss vor das antik mal
würmer und grillgasse wie ungesalzene
gesamten geschäfts das ist ja überhaupt
nichts das schmeckt noch gar nichts das
könnte ihm lassen essen auch kein summe
käme mir regeln auf sondern man stellt
sich wirklich eklat hatte davor hat man
das gefühl ich esse ungesalzene
schmecken ja nichts mit dem motto wird
liebe grete und haben wir lachen über
sich plädoyer medienpartner allergenes
spargel paket wie genau soll ich meinen
partner sehen wenn ich ihn sehe wie man
sparen gesehen hat was ist die neue
perspektive man betrachtete spargeln die
wir schon so oft gesehen haben genauer
und sah wie schön sie sind und wer sein
bild anschaut entdeckt diese schönheit
denn man hatte den impuls genauer
hinzusehen und tod und wenn man so eine
grenzerfahrung übersteht ist es wie eine
wiedergeburt
ich gehe gegen den selbsterhaltungstrieb
das ist das stärkste trieb den wir haben
da hinauf um nicht umzukommen und wenn
es mir gelingt nicht umzukommen ist das
anschließend wie eine wiedergeburt und
das ist vermutlich der hintergrund
warum wir das immer wieder tun dass da
eine art wiederholungszwang auftritt ich
sage nicht eine sucht da sind ja keine
objekte im spiel höchstens körpereigene
aber es hat einen wiederholungszwang in
sich weil ist es wieder geboren sein
dieses gefühl wieder geboren zu sein
ein sehr starkes gefühl ist was ist das
für ein gefühl können sie das noch näher
beschreiben
ich habe das ganze leben vor mir wie ich
habe das ganze ja wieder auszufüllen ich
kann mein leben mit neuen ideen
ausfüllen
ich habe es mir selber erobert joachim 2
1 2 stunden die erste sternstunde kann
ich das so klug schön dass für das ist
das schwierige situationen künstliche
situation er ist nervös war ich
eigentlich verfehlung abgelenkt punkt
sprechen was man mit sie hätten ohrwurm
darin dass retter betroffen hier das
konzept mit vorbereiteten vorgenommen
sagt igor irre wenn man zu hause
was aber immer die frage im kopf zu
hause kamera sowas licht blendet und das
ist für mich die große herausforderung
auch heute noch das ausblenden und
fokussiere routiniert ja ja aber es ist
gesprochen
das meistens zwei gäste nicht mehr
wusste das ist eben nicht alles versteht
nicht wie spd du bist in eine
wildkirsche nervös das nicht was sie
schon immer noch schafft so eine
grundsätzliche panik würde ich mal sagen
ja brasilien finden auch so die spannung
zwischen jedis sternstunde stand strom
wasser oder als radikale tosca und
irgendwo oder willst du musst gastspiel
lohn erhalten wie die stange halten
duschen ein sitzgefühl das obwohl ich
das endlich vertrauen dass sie möglich
versuchen ins und landsitz bringen und
auf der anderen seite als förderer und
nicht alles so dass der gast absolut
verdient so wohl fühlt in dem zwiespalt
ist gut zu bringen
die spannung ist natürlich da gehörte
dazu und fotos
mit ok sendet und möglichen rät graszt
und bananen tut das sehr schön bist du
aber bedauert gange und hätte sogar
tipps vom social media experte robert
bossmann of screen ich habe ihn ja
gesagt ich bin neu auf facebook und ich
wollte die gelegenheit nutzen den
professor für digitale medien hier zu
haben was soll ich denn nun als erstes
posten auf meiner seite
sie haben gerade einen facebook account
eröffnen haben sie das profil schon
ausgefüllt das hat man schon gemacht das
ist ganz wichtig dann würde ich sagen
als erste meldung natürlich unbedingt im
sinne der selbstwerbung dir üblich ist
auf facebook schreiben sie doch dass sie
gerade ein erhebendes gespräch über die
abgründe von facebook hatten
und vergessen sie nicht meinen namen mit
einzugeben und natürlich den link dann
zum video
damit jeder darauf drücken können ok
also eigenwerbung muss sein das habe ich
schon mal gelernt fällt mir ein bisschen
schwer aber machen wir jetzt so link
mache ich später dazu ist gepostet ich
bedanke mich sehr
ich bedanke mich auch für die erwähnung
seines namens ja wie herstellt so mit
facebook ich glaube so bliebe wenig
erwartet dass es durch die teils teils
inside das auf der einschätzung der
ausdrucksmittel zuschauer und
zuschauerinnen extrem freue mich
wirklich über ein relativ großes
feedback und überholen
meine schafe kiwis oder tipps oder frage
und auf der anderen seite ist halt
genauso wie florian tasten kürzlich
gleitet interessant relevante anzahl
klicks und das bisherige tieren zwar ist
ein knipser geholt und war es an und
suchen uns gott für mich ganz klar auf
kosten von 50 lassen und das ist für
mich im raum schwierig ist einfach sehr
gut
am ende dass jordan oder über facebook
gerät sondern über digitalisierung im
generelle und ich hatte den world web
forum in zürich mit 2 experte mit
künstlicher intelligenz reiter und
fragesteller maschine eigentlichen
kreativ sie und wendet ein ganz
besonderer gast kam jetzt kriegen wir
besuch von einem überraschungsgast
das ist papa ein humanoider roboter und
hering bringt den zu uns möchte mal
hallo sagen hey das ist die handschrift
und vielleicht mal schauen ja ist
zukünftig bis zur künstlichen
intelligenz ist noch etwas weitergehen
kreativität ist eines der dinge
wovon man sagt dass maschinen das so
schnell nicht können dass wir menschen
das nach den maschinen voraus haben wie
lange dauert das denn ihrer meinung nach
bis maschinen kreativ sein können
erklärt aufmerksam ist erkennt hinweise
auf das was in den nächsten fünf bis
zehn jahren geschehen wird verpasst man
diese signale schluss das gilt auch im
hinblick auf die technologien wie bei
diesen roboter vor ein paar jahren gab
es einfachere roboter die sich
weiterentwickelt haben und entwickeln
werden
technologien also nicht anhand des
heutigen zustand sondern ihre
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten innerhalb
einer bestimmten bandbreite wie wir
müssen bereit sein uns anzupassen an
diese herausforderungen mit all ihren
vor und nachteilen
so sehen wir das wir haben ein
zeitfenster von fünf bis zehn jahren und
schritte zu unternehmen und zu reagieren
auch ohne zu wissen wohin genau die
reise geht
aber das ist in ordnung erekat nicht
wirklich fest ob kreativität der schöne
vorbehalten ist aber ein anderer gast
und kann leichter juval harari mit dem
buch von models 2010 hat daher der ganze
quartier team einig zum thema
kreativität und ich habe im studio auch
die musik vorgespielt wovon eine
maschine komponiert worden ist kennen
die diese musik
[Musik]
ich kenne dieses bestimmte stück nicht
aber im buch beschreibe ich ein
computerprogramm das musik im stil von
johann sebastian bach komponiert und die
meisten menschen können wie auch ich den
unterschied zwischen seine musik und der
computer komposition nicht erkennen das
computerprogramm kaum zu schreiben sie
5000 choräle in einem tag komponieren
und wenn es um kunst geht stellt sich
einmal mehr eine philosophische frage
was ist die wichtigste aufgabe der kunst
gewisse leute finden kunst solle vor
allem gefühle auslösen
doch wenn kunst emotionen wecken soll
werden computer sehr bald viel bessere
künstler sein als menschen
denn aufgrund ihrer datenmenge und
rechenleistung können sie viel besser
mit unseren emotionen spielen als jeder
menschliche künstler
sie verfügen nicht über eigene emotionen
computer haben kein bewusstsein sie
haben keine gefühle
aber sie haben die fähigkeit die
emotionen der menschen viel präziser zu
manipulieren oder zu inspirieren als
jeder menschliche künstlich programm so
gut sind dass man eben gehört und
trotzdem glaube ich dass die musik denen
andere weltkriege der einfach mehr
wüsste dass von einer maschine
komponiert ist unendlich schwierig
glaubt das extrem starke emotionen
auslösen sowie das musik von beethoven
oder verbraucher macht aber klar die
kunst strom
bus zurück gefühl ausdrücken und der
mensch verstanden wird also wenn ich
beethoven lasse dann hätte ich den
schmerz spüren verstanden werden und
wenn ich weiß dass eine maschine
komponiert verliert das sind reits dass
man das musikstück
ich weiß nicht wie es später ich würde
aber sagen dass ich ein guter
unterschied der maschine wo bach
komponiert muss ich wirklich sagen muss
ich aber ich finde generell die ganze
frage was eigentlich mit einer
künstlerin die ganze show jetzt darüber
diskutiert wo das die letzten vier
punkte singularität dass irgendein
maschinen übernahme entschieden werden
wie der mensch und so sehr die story
vorstellung achtung jetzt gut maschinen
und alles wird überrollt und
skrupellosen schienen eines jetzt glaube
ich tatsächlich nicht dass das jetzt
passiert ist nur mehr beschäftigt ist
dass es einfach so viel die studie geht
bezüglich der technik geht wenig
positive technik entwirft und das licht
verändert wenn man zurückblickt und
diesem zusammenhang ist während des
gespräches in katalonien die feministin
wo seit das eigentlich science fiction
für sie die große utopie maschinen ist
wo man eben arbeitet positiv über
technik gedanke nicht wichtig dass man
die sachen versucht positive bilder aus
danke was mit der technik nur alles
könnte sich positive utopie war
technisch zu beschreibt ist
verschmelzung von mensch und maschine
und hoffe nicht dass man irgendeine
schwert können
unsterblich sie und das ist bloss aus
temax sie mit dem judo harari abra mit
dem jonas rummel ob das mal kurz was dir
zeug dazu sagen sie sagen der tod wird
in zukunft mit dieser parteiischen
revolution mit der revolution zum homo
dem skin ein technisches problem werden
und das ist ja auch etwas was viele
touristen sagen ray kurzweil ist ein
berühmtes beispiel dafür
zusammen mit einem google subunternehmen
sind sie daran den tod abzuschaffen sie
sagen bereits 2050 werden die regelmäßig
hingehen
einen biologischen reset button drücken
können uns generalüberholen lassen und
dann können wir locker 400 jahre alt
werden glauben sie das wirklich
ich denke dass es noch verfrüht
im jahr 2050 werden wir noch nicht die
nötige technologie haben um das leben
unendlich fortsetzen zu können
doch in ein oder zwei 100 jahren könnte
es durchaus möglich sein
ich denke es kommen auch viele probleme
auf uns zu wenn wir das leben beliebig
verlängern können
zuerst einmal wird es wahrscheinlich
sehr teuer sein
zumindest für die ersten generationen
also haben nur die reichen die chance
jahrhundertelang schön und jung zu
bleiben
das wird gewaltige wut auslösen in der
armen bevölkerung
denn während der bisherigen
menschheitsgeschichte war der tod die
große ausgleichende macht die armen
konnten sagen die reichen haben zwar ein
gutes leben aber sie müssen wie wir
sterben
doch stellen sie sich eine welt vor in
dir nur die armen sterben und die
reichen weiterleben das wird viele
wütend machen
und wer reich ist hat viel mehr angst
als zuvor denn wir reden hier nicht von
unsterblichkeit
sie können immer noch sterben sie haben
die möglichkeit unendlich zu leben dank
neuer behandlungen aber wenn sie zb von
einem auto überfahren werden sind sie
tot das kann niemand rückgängig machen
die angst vor dem tod wird also größer
sein denn je die menschen werden keine
risiken eingehen wollen
es war heute riskant hierher zu reisen
das flugzeug hätte abstürzen können doch
da ich so oder so sterben werde bin ich
bereit gewisse risiken einzugehen
aber da viele die chance ewig zu leben
nicht verpassen wollen weil sie diesen
oder jenen fehler machen gibt es wohl
nicht nur mehr wut sondern auch viel
mehr angst als je zuvor
ich glaube das nicht dass wir so weit
kommen werden dass unsere körper
unsterblich werden
da ist die biologie einfach nicht dazu
ausgerüstet selbst wenn wir noch so gut
dazu gucken und zell
erneuerungsmaßnahmen und weiß der teufel
was ich glaube unsterblichkeit wird er
irgendwann eine möglichkeit sein im
sinne des dass wir erinnerungen und das
selbst so irgendwie auf eine festplatte
laden können und dann in neue grappa
oder auch maschinen weiter laufen lassen
dass diese ganzen trans humanistischen
überlegungen von verschmelzungen
zwischen körper und maschine und die
irgendwann eines tages vermutlich
realität werden wird
ich denke nicht zu unseren lebzeiten
wobei man weiß manchmal verdammt schnell
und dann spielt natürlich dieses risiko
dann wieder gar keine rolle mehr so dann
ist man ja wirklich also gut da muss man
angst davor haben dass irgendwie ist man
auseinandergeschraubt ja oder die
festplatte auf der man seine sicherheit
und wie gespeichert hat dass die
irgendwie runterfällt oder gehängt
ein virus erwischt so wirst du
eigentlich wer ewig dabei wenn man
deswegen gleich manchmal muss man ja
sagen hat das mit dem aber keine von der
festplatte zeigt dass der user die art
von sterblichkeit im kopf wo man sind
sie herr nicht quasi und salat und einen
neuen körper wieder läuft und das finde
ich war um so absolut wie es so ganz
starke liebt sehen die atommacht als
nehrig nicht armin coerper ich habe
keine anderen körper wieder existieren
sind sie schon philosophisch gesehen
relativ bezahlen aber es gibt ja noch
die andere vorstellung mit der
biologischen und sterblichkeit dass man
den zelltod und ich muss ehrlich sagen
ich jetzt alles nicht groß fasziniert
ich finde der werk zum moment ist gerade
so großartige immer schon weiß dass
jetzt an die gott also bekannt sich vom
schöner ist doch das muss gut aus macht
das motiv von carpe diem macht ja nur
sehen die analysten eine scheibe fertig
das schönste moment von ihm lautet du
ich werde sterben und darum hat
ich muss gestehen nein nicht ganz die
tanke ich werde sterben aber es müsse
darum dass sache endlich sind und dass
nicht alles nötige repetition ist finde
ich eigentlich gut aber es ist doch
petition durch durchaus sich immer
wieder neu und war verordnete wir schon
300 400 500 jahre alt dunkel aber
durchaus ein top model war der spieler
so viele andere thema wenn sie mal
wieder langlebigkeit drei oder vier 100
jahre heißt ein immer noch ein tod nach
400 jahren als virtueller 400 urlaub
werden
ich finde das so eigenartig so eine
frage stellen will ich einfach glaube es
gehört im moment zu wünscht sie extrem
dazu dass man so eine spanne im kopf
setzen
80 mitglieder 100 jahre und es wird ganz
neue modell bruch es wird zum beispiel
soll seriell lebensmodell den geraer
dass man nicht mehr alles im lack kinder
über hunt dass man serielle partner hat
das mit micky brühl hat und das kann ich
hoffe ich reizvoll im moment aber es ist
einfach nur dumm ich jetzt per se
wahnsinnig interessiert aber ich bin so
also wenn man neugierige ich natürlich
was in zukunft nur aus virtual slogan
wir die letzte jahrzehnt rock was
passiert ist finde ich schon entspannen
die vorstellig oder reizvolle
vorstellung noch viel länger
ich würde es werden ja also ich würde
das komme den entscheider also dass
suizid ist ja immer noch eine lösung ich
glaube wenn man weiß man ist gefangen
ewiger und tanja dusy ich habe das ist
die form vor allem strom oder empfindet
und punkt vor bequem ich vor dem hermes
werk immer noch glaubt philosophie hat
die standspur und immer auch die größere
zusammenhalts lage zu sorgen und das
chinesische frau gesperrtem einstellung
aber auszusprechen jahres so petra thees
die antwort dass man seit naja egal wie
man immer noch möglichkeit von
selbstmord von suizid
aber das ist ganz andere erfahrung
vertont will das wählt man unter sich in
bestimmten tag ich weiß nicht wie groß
aber ich würde
wir wissen aber einen tag ich sterbe
fängt das trio stellen
das gehört doch dazu hat das wir
überrascht wird vom tod oder dass man
nämlich gespült aber wenn du jetzt wirst
dich misst das datum ist genau kaya nik
am 17 januar zur musik und 87
kann ich das gut ich glaube müsse sich
daran gewöhnen also jetzt gehört haben
oder zur dass man es noch nicht weiß
aber natürlich in zukunft so das
festkleid zudem kaum unternehmen noch
starten hatte oder das ist das radio aus
dass ich da ich brauche mal einen kaffee
oder tee
[Musik]
die griechin kraft und natürlich ich es
vergesse alle regeln hier vergangen oder
bio
im jahr 2010 sei eigentlich eine
schlussrate machen ring gepushte
untersagen biopic ein riesenthema
aber es ist sandig den wir so zurück wie
es magisch fortschritt wurde ein gast
nach einem anderen irgendwie vor
laufender kamera zeit übrigens vergangen
oder ich schieße mit sicherheit kann
sich also maschine war dixie für
vegetarismus wenn es ums überleben geht
dann ist das töten eines tieres aus
meiner sicht ein vernünftiger grund dann
sind wir uns allerdings einig dass in
unseren gesellschaften des nirgends
worum es überleben diesbezüglich mehr
geht
also wir brauchen kein fleisch nein das
weiß jeder dass der mensch kein fleisch
braucht man kann lange darüber streiten
ob es wirklich gesund es sich vegan zu
ernähren da bin ich auch kein experte
aber vegetarier zu sein es medizinisch
unbedenklich ist es sogar unterm strich
gesünder
ich finde es wunderbar am leben zu sein
ich würde das leben eines anderen tieres
nicht beenden wollen
ich würde andere tiere auch nicht
grausam behandeln bloß weil ich sie
essen will
aus diesem grund esse ich kein tier
leben ist wertvoll
ich habe mich vor fünf jahren dazu
entschieden veganer zu werden als
experiment
ich fühlte mich gesünder also blieb ich
dabei für mich ist der tod von
nicht-menschlichen tieren moralisch
gesehen eine ernsthafte angelegenheit
darüber sollten wir gut nachdenken bevor
wir in einen burger beißen denn es
grenzt an einen kannibalischen akt
ich bin kein vegetarier aber ich agiere
nahe an der grenze zum kannibalismus
das bringt mich in einen anstrengenden
moralischen rechtfertigungsdruck
man muss schon ein sehr großes vergnügen
dabei empfinden um das töten unseres
evolutionären cousins zu rechtfertigen
wäre es nicht konsequent wenn sie weil
garanten leben würden ja sie haben
gerade gesagt ob es eigentlich
konsequent und ich würde sagen
eigentlich ist das konsequent aber ich
bin nicht konsequent ich bin ich
konsequent weil es in der moral am ende
auch nicht drauf ankommt dass wir in
allen moralischen fragen unausgesetzt
konsequent sind das kann nicht das ziel
sein also am ende müsste dann das ziel
der ethik darin bestehen dass jeder ein
heiliger wird ich akzeptiere das finde
das wunderbar wenn jemand veganer ist
aber ich kann den maßstab dass es im
leben darauf ankommt ein durch und durch
guter mensch zu sein dann kann ich nicht
teilen
die auch uns im labor ich darauf ab dass
man durch und durch guter mensch ist
sich rechnete ganz sieht und alles 000
brillen hallo
aber natürlich ganz anders ich habe das
problem mit dem ich irgendwie sagen mich
irritiert dass ich das in letzter zeit
so viel zu tun dass er moral und kurze
touren besonders dreas problem also
quasi ich kann im tennis spielen
ich habe im slalom muss ein moralischer
mensch sehnt war geradezu im bereich von
hoffenheim in der cdu gesehen dass das
überhaupt muss stimmen machen sehr
vereinfachen und trotzdem auf diese
kriterien moralisch aufgehört zu tag
fleisch essen ökologische bilanz so
schlecht ist und die ethische gründe und
wie hängt das immer wieder geschafft und
händen philosophische animationsfilm
hergestellt in der reihe viel los so fix
genau zu dem thema
[Musik]
stell dir vor du wurst aus dem schlaf
gerissen
[Applaus]
heerscharen von aliens überfallen
unseren planeten
[Applaus]
sie sind uns körperlich geistig und
technologisch weit überlegen
wir müssen für sie schuften und sie
nutzen uns für medizinische versuche
manche von uns lügen sie auch mit ihnen
herum zu teilen und zu knuddeln
aber nicht alle menschen haben das glück
dass haustiere eines aliens zu sein
sie verspeisen uns menschen genüsslich
am liebsten zartes kinder fleisch
[Musik]
den frauen pumpen sie die milch ab und
machen daraus leckere drinks millionen
von menschen werden eingesperrt und
gemessen
anschließend geschlachtet
[Applaus]
völlig empört rennst du zum anführer und
stellt ihn zur rede
so kann das doch nicht weitergehen
wie könnt ihr nur so grausam sein wir
brauchen eier fleisch
es ist lecker und reich an proteinen und
wir brauchen euch für medizinische
versuche was rettet dich so auf mich
nach dir nicht dasselbe mit ihren
lehrern
du verlierst den boden unter den füßen
hat der außerirdische nicht recht
verhalten wir uns tieren gegenüber nicht
genau so dürfen wir tieren etwas antun
was man uns nicht antun darf analogie ja
es ist verstörend aber ich glaube es ist
wichtig dass man den perspektivwechsel
macht und das ist jede moral hat bisher
sehr wichtig und ich glaube es hat sich
nicht grün und also nehm ich schon sagen
was ist eigentlich warum dürfen mit
ihrer bist du was menschen mit der frage
was warum sind die so verschieden
ich habe diesen dicken hier weniger klug
oder den server krass moralisch sind
aber es geht halt viele menschen wo das
auch nicht hin zum beispiel südlichen
oderbruch sehr stark dement ist und die
behandlung mit dir und ich finde dass es
sehr gut sagen meint zumindest wie hast
du mit dem fleisch seien ja eigentlich
fleisch künftig wieder zu uns anderen
ist sie mit fleisch kochen oder mit
ihnen kein fleisch isst aber insgesamt
logisch so extrem auf dass du nicht
langgasse jetzt ist sie weder ich finds
aber immer noch eigentlich falsch laufe
seiner inneren konflikte aber ich find's
einfach sehr verein und bin konsequent
das ist dem thema bevor er oder
zumindest schön dabei kürzlich hatte zu
wenig energie und so viel leid die ganze
kultur technik aber nicht ein anderes
die moralische verfall hätten fragen
bezüglich den klimawandel beschäftigen
sind zum ersten mal am stammtisch nach
basel ist lokal sucht und hat extra
diskutiert ob man über hunderte flüge in
den letzten wochen und monaten konnte
man ja kaum eine zeitung aufschlagen
ohne dass einem das thema des
klimawandels entgegentrat
und meistens auch verbunden mit der
frage was ist eigentlich mit dem
vermehrten flugaufkommen die taten
wahrheit haben sich die flüge in den
letzten 20 jahren verdoppelt weltweit
gesehen und welche verantwortung haben
eigentlich genau sie und ich angesichts
des klimawandels ist es denn wirklich
ein problem also ist fliegen ein thema
der moral sag ich jetzt mal drei
zentimeter es ist ganz vieles ein thema
der moralischen letztliche moral hat ja
auch damit zu tun was ich mache ich muss
wissen was es tun wenn ich weiß wo die
möglichen schäden sind dann kann ich
mich so verhalten
aber dann muss ich sagen okay fliegen
ist moralisch fleisch essen ist und also
ist unmoralisch fleisch essen ist
unmoralisch wenn ich mich überhaupt so
viel bewege ist unmoralisch wenn ich
atme ist unmoralisch wenn wir quasi bei
diesem luftverschmutzung thema sind und
so weiter und so fort am schluss muss
ich sagen der mensch ist unmoralisch
eigentlich die tatsache dass wir da sind
schon unmoralisch und damit sind wir
gehen wir schon recht weit und glaube
ich dann ist er dann anfang ins detail
zu gehen
und was das moralische angeht kann man
ja sagen soll man auf einer abstrakten
ebene sind wir jetzt alle ganz moralisch
betroffen dass wir uns falsch verhalten
im rahmen der wirtschafts form in der
wir existieren verhalten wir uns ja hoch
moralisch wir sollen ja immer mehr
kaufen wir sollen immer mehr reisen wir
sollen immer mehr irgendwelche dinge
nehmen und wegschmeißen usw
das heißt die moral diskussion ist er
schon mal völlig abstrahiert von dem was
eigentlich erforderlich ist damit der
laden funktioniert und dass das problem
und wir haben eben seit 200 jahren
mobilität fixiert auf allen ebenen und
das wirklich philosophisch diskutieren
wollte und nicht um prozentzahlen
streiten will oder um technologische
mögliche möglichkeiten das ein bisschen
zu reduzieren treibstoff ausstoß ein
bisschen zu reduzieren durch bessere
motoren oder e mobilität für flugzeuge
irgendjemand wird auch auf diese idee
kommen immer das nicht auf den tisch
neben diskutieren wollen müssen wir
überhaupt einmal hinterfragen dieses
mobilitätskonzept ja es steht ja auch
nirgendwo geschrieben dass sich kreuz
und quer
er hat bei zu bewegen an sich und wert
sein soll
man kann ja genau so die these vertreten
es wäre besser gerade doch in dem sinne
der philosophie der leute wie im sowie
kant in königsberg bleiben akku game und
mal ordentlich nachdenken dann kommen
solche ja warum blieben
danke danke dass ich meine unbequem ist
naja aber die menschlichkeit mobilität
ist günstig es ist unglaublich attraktiv
und sich zum teil der schweiz wir jetzt
machen wir irgendwo ins südliche land
züge aber gleichzeitig finde die show
muss ich aufpassen reise mit tragischer
verkehrsmittel oder umweltverträglichere
und das finde ich extrem schön sondern
ich überlege was hat mich immer im leben
gefragt den körper zu sicher aus
bahnreisen wobei die große reise die
mache ich wirklich sehr wohl dass ich
mich einer hand abzählen und den
reisepreis hier langsam und leise mit
lokalen rechtsmittel
ja ich mache es kann doch auf eine große
reise machen versuche lengerich vor zwei
jahren
der kolumbier zum beispiel der gesamte
woche muss ich ab und zu flüge
beruflich das ist so wie ich versuche
irgendwie ich finde die dosis macht's
und überleg ich stelle und traf mich wie
viel dafür flüge und versucht frau
gemeinde wenn alle menschen so viele
wörter wird sein überhaupt noch
funktioniert das alte kroatische regler
vor der universalisierung konnte ich
versuche so zu machen problem natürlich
ist das ökologische fußabdruck
ramazzotti gang die viel größere wieder
underlying aufgrund der tatsache wie
viel wohnraum mehr brauchen die
mehrheits etwas einrastet also also ganz
allein stand dachte ich natürlich
wirklich nicht rechtfertigen soll
leistungsstärker werden
das ist spannende frage altersjahr
dürfte mit dem ergometer das schon
zurich film festival und das eigentlich
überraschende wie sehr optimistisch die
welt befindet sich gerade im frühen
stadium einer globalen
nachhaltigkeitsrevolution ermöglicht
durch digitale werkzeuge wie die
künstliche intelligenz das internet der
dinge
sie hat den umfang der industriellen
revolution aber mit der geschwindigkeit
der digitalen revolution
sie ist eine realität in unserem leben
und wir sollten sie als basis für echte
hoffnung wahrnehmen
wir können das lösen wir werden es lösen
die entscheidende frage ist wie schnell
wir sie lösen werden und dass wir darauf
vertrauen können den point of no return
nicht zu überschreiten
er hat ja schon oft für dieses an die
kleider die medien haben wir in zukunft
also ich habe zum beispiel dauert die
partie schon ganz viele gefragt aber
immer mal wieder die schweiz aber bis
jetzt haben es geschafft mit ihren
wesentlich wahnsinnig machen gerade
jetzt in der ganzen debatte um
journalismus feminismus war auch von
sexismus und den gast und ich eigentlich
immerhin hilft der harry frankfurt eine
ganz große philosoph 25 stellen
mitglieder 21 jahrhundert unter anderem
ein bullshit geschrieben und er ist so
gut dass sie das bereuen und bei der
begriffe plastisch 2007 im letzten
januar und hätten zum thema angst
eigentlich alles weg nur noch einer
sagen ja ich hatte auch noch eine
südkoreanische insel haben wo man
versichert ist oder eine diagnostik das
wissen ist auch ein punkt bringt zum
beispiel die art von politik wo man
heute oft betrieb derzeitigen nachhaltig
der schutz bietet und wird machen wir
das leidenschaftlich freiwillig
verantwortung das finde ich spannend ist
oder natürlich solid wieder profitieren
die man unbedingt mal ist es anders ist
sich chancenlos aber mehr probiert es
mal probiert und die große
kapitalismuskritiker in der uniklinik
es ist frisch und werden oft zu wenig
frauen gute gäste sparen sind die klagen
dank der daniel barenboim damals aber
betrüger lang probiert besonderen denn
möglich wurde kamera kann aber es lohnt
sich genau wäre auch nicht wo im moment
die spanische coach wo die wichtigste
stimme wenn es um rassismus gott in den
usa aber bald wieder ganz ganz große us
amerikanische intellektuelle wo mich
wahnsinnig interessiert und einen
totalen kram passt für mich der woody
allen ich bin großer woody allen filme
nachts hoch philosophisch und wunderbar
lustig und komisch dass ein großer
schulterzucken schlagen natürlich mit
sollten immer noch mal mit dem
management in kontakt die mal dass ich
schon aber es heißt ein immer häufiger
zieht wahrscheinlich eine sprechende
tiere sind und wie man ist haben wir ein
glück die chance und pflanzen zum
beispiel wer gerne strickt sie ist aber
seit dem zeitplan her
wir können viel vor
und übrigens wenn sie die heimatfreunde
dies wirklich immer über ivi ist über
ideen für ihre siebte speziell an
philosophie at / punkt ch oder via
facebook und den prüfen wir gerne
vorschläge
wir haben nach so liese glücks mitte
eine kluge liebte so lange sprach vier
stunden am tag x die hintergrund
diskutieren und deshalb bis in die
heutige zeit im rahmen wird er stichwort
schnelle medien soziale medien fake news
verschwörungstheorie und so wiederum
zudem zu den themen er seinen weg
gemacht und die melodie diesmal avid
expert eigentlich das definiert fake
news und verschwörungstheorien versuchen
wir nochmal einzugrenzen was fehlt news
und wenn ich jetzt zum beispiel tage die
sternstunde philosophie sind das
weltweit populärste philosophie format
dann ist das vielleicht richtig oder
falsch ich weiß es gar nicht ist das
schon fake news sind flunkereien oder
scherzhafte übertreibung fake news oder
gibt es da eine definitorischen
bestimmung die sagen das macht nix zu
fuß wir haben soeben ein buch über fake
news geschrieben
in diesem buch klassifizieren wir
verschiedene aussagen ob sie als fake
news gelten oder nicht zuoberst in der
scala zum ersten bereich gehören setzte
die klare fakten ausdrücken
hier ist ein glas wasser sie tragen eine
brille und so weiter
das sind die geprüften fakten und gleich
eine stufe weiter unten gibt es
fabrizierte fakten aber wenn sie wollen
manipulierte aussagen
sie sind nicht unbedingt falsch sie
könnten zugeschnitten sagen was ist
ihnen lieber 90% beschäftigungen oder
zehn prozent arbeitslosigkeit unter dem
strich ist es das gleiche es geht über
selektionen wie man die dinge
präsentiert selektion wie man etwas
präsentiert rosinenpicken oder gewisse
fakten unterschlagen usw an dritter
stelle kommt das gerücht gerüchte können
wahr oder falsch seien
dann haben sie das was harry frankfurt
bullshit etwas das absichtlich keinen
unterschied zwischen wahrheit und
unwahrheit macht da gibt es lügen die
grundsätzlich falsch sind und
schließlich haben sie fällt - als
letzten punkt
die fake news sind in der regel ein
nischenprodukt das aber als echte
aktuelle news geschichte präsentiert
wird das macht sie speziell gefährlich
nicht weil zwangsläufig alles falsch ist
sondern weil es sich dabei um eine
vorgespielte realität handelt sie kommen
als ersatz realität daher
dadurch sind sie viel schwieriger zu
entlarven weil die gängigen kriterien
zur entlassung von behauptungen ganz
anders sind auch aus philosophischer
sicht ist das wirklich gift parasitäre
systeme die eigentlich aufsetzen auf
waren nachrichten und sich so geben
verkleiden und dann eine misch zone
gründen nein bleiben dann legen die
chemtrails die das irgendwie
kondensstreifen das flugzeug die chemie
verbreiten die klimalüge usw
ja wir müssen erklären was überhaupt
eine verschwörungstheorie ist gibt es so
etwas wie eine akzeptable definition
also ja in der forschung gibt es
eigentlich einen konsens eine
verschwörungstheorie ist eine theorie
die erklärt dass ein historisches
ereignis
sozusagen von einer kleinen gruppe von
eingeweihten im geheim durchgeführt
wurde und sozusagen eine andere version
offiziell verbreitet wird das heißt
verschwörungstheorien sind eigentlich
meistens theorien der macht und zwar
einer geheimen macht strippenzieher die
im geheimen agieren und die ist
sozusagen dann eine eine coverstory
darüber breiten und
verschwörungstheorien haben immer und
das ist eigentlich auch ganz interessant
die tendenz sozusagen offizielle
wahrheiten zu hinterfragen und auf diese
diese dieses komplott durchgreifen zu
wollen
man könnte sagen macht und wissen das
wissen wir dann unterdrückt es gibt ein
geheim
ich würde sagen verschwörungstheorien
neben diesen inhaltlichen definitionen
sind auch ein denkstil oder eine
bestimmte psychische haltung und gegen
die rutschen wir ist an mir selber
gezeigt habe relativ leicht rein dann
ist plötzlich alles klar
und es ist faszinierend es ist nicht
diese blöde gewöhnliche geschichte in
der wir sind sondern es wird aufregend
ist irgendwie komisch schwierigsten eine
kosmische uhr das sind die top 5 bild
wie ihr vater und ich gerade immanuel
kant mit dem begriff der rasenden und wo
eigentlich zu wort wo alles wird der
klare wahrscheinlich für mich zu suchen
in den decken jahr 2007 zeit dass die
komplexe welt nicht nur verlangt auf
vernunft appellieren sondern auch
mitunter einheitlichen umgang und
angeschafft bescheide sie und über das
post faktische die totale institute in
rüschlikon diskutiert mit dem ilja
trojanow unter lorin dachten ich habe
schon gesagt man sagt die wahrheit
stecke in einer krise wie sieht denn
diese krise auch wenn sie darauf klicken
zuerst für sich sorgen es ist keine
krise der wahrheit keine krise der
fakten die wahrheiten die fakten sind
was sie immer waren es ist eine krise
von wissen und die quellen von wissen es
ist auch eine krise von vertrauen wem
dürfen wir vertrauen und eine krise auch
vielleicht von medienbildung wie gehen
wir mit den neuen medien um glaube es
ist an der zeit diese stimmen hier auch
anzuhören
deswegen gebe ich gerne ihnen das wort
stellen sie gerne ihre fragen was also
mich würde interessieren sie beide wie
optimistisch sind sie denn jetzt gerade
bezug auf solche fake news auf solche
gegen wahrheiten also erfundene gegen
verhalten bei denen ein unglaublich
großer einerseits anreiz da ist auch ein
unglaublicher macht und geld geld
dahinter steht kapital dahinter steht
das zu steuern und gleichzeitig auch die
technischen möglichkeiten sie haben es
erwähnt mit mit facebook des fast
weltumspannend ist
dass man trotz dieser vielen
herausforderungen optimistisch bleiben
kann und sagt wir wir lösen dieses
problem auf welche weise auch immer
ja also ich bin insofern optimistisch
weil ich glaube dass und der
gesellschaft in der ich leben wird
nämlich an der wirklich in jeder
hinsicht durch und durch demokratische
freiheitliche gesellschaft sich das
problem weniger stellt also ich glaube
dass das tram problem im moment der form
darin besteht dass er überhaupt kein
interesse daran hat ob irgendeine
aussage wahr ist oder nicht
er hat ja mehr mehrmals völlige lügen
zitiert als man ihn konfrontiert hat mit
der tatsache dass sie falsch sind hat er
gesagt na ja ich habe es im internet
gelesen wer bin ich zu überprüfen ob
stimmt nicht und das ist ja sozusagen
das zentrale dass er und ich nenne jetzt
nur repräsentativ für eine entwicklung
überhaupt nicht sich die wahrheit frage
gestellt und das ist ja leninistischer
also es dient jetzt einen bestimmten
zweck
ergo kann ich das in die welt
hinausposaunen da sehe ich tatsächlich
eher eine machtfrage anhangs gemacht und
fertig ich glaube es gibt gar kein hang
es geht zusammenhang zwischen macht und
meinige werden einfach die mächtige
meinen körper floss aber trabis ganz
anders wort ist sozusagen ganz
traditionell wurde das theorie sei die
stimmung ist einmalig oder vorstellungen
mit der realität wie sie wirklich und
die realität kann man nicht verändere
mich als sozusagen einige d köpfe
anderer verliert das klappt realität
nicht gibt es denn die realität
ich glaube die geht's wir können nicht
erkennen
darum würde ich mich sauber die
skeptiker bezeichnet
aber es ist ein wichtiger punkt nämlich
auch sagen was nützt diesen worten wir
waren dran aber was will die jeder
zugang zur wirklichkeit läuft über diese
vorstellung über böse geister eigentlich
oder mich und eigentlich hier wie sie
vorstellungen mit dem wirklich erwartete
hinter friedlichere welt
jeder zugegangen ist schon mental das
ist das problem
was ist zwischen zwei mal gemacht und
antwort also warten fordert wirklich
schön wie du was ich im moment
interessanter in die scheide zusammen
zuschauer macht und will seinerseits
eigentlich gehts zur demokratisierung
vom müsse mit der ganzen digitalisierung
also hätte dass wikipedia informationen
und wissen ist eigentlich frei
zugänglich und das merkt man jetzt
stimmt aber nur das frucht einer sitz
bild man muss keine mit der
informationsflut umgang muss keine
unterscheiden und für das braucht
natürlich einen stand sowohl die
unterscheidung für alles machen sagt
roller von den medien ist natürlich eine
wo immer wichtiger wird oder wo wir neue
muss diskutieren und musste was dir
heißt denn im digitalen zeitalter um das
buch medienkompetenz vor der leserinnen
und leser dass man der schule wie
bringen die 40 lang alle roxy und ich
habe gemerkt irgendwie ein bisschen
müsse recherchieren im internet oder
regen welche medien zitieren und sowas
ist so schwierig oder und das muss man
nicht mehr mit ihrer flotte und
komplexität können uns glauben die selbe
programm geriet nach eines aus verträgen
wie möglich an dieses jahres meistern
oder mehr innere parallel arbeiten
landet und algorithmen andere schreibung
ich meine scham beschäftigt ist dass ich
mir mit guten oder treffer wohl sagen
ich widme mich interessiert an
information nicht wirklich ich finde es
gar nicht so wichtig was erwartet das
passierte schlug ministerien oder
instagram unterwegs und erfahren was für
mich wichtig ist wenn ich meine
natürlich bedeutet informiert sie auch
macht insofern dass nach angriffen und
sogar innere direkter demokratie haben
sie eine stimme haben und sich wehren
als henry setzte also sprichwörtlich
innere demokratie ich glaube aber dass
das schon früher aktiv das einfach glück
nicht interessiert sind und ich glaube
sie mich war die grad ist sie die ganze
wieder heute -leser tätige wo 400 zieht
die klassen der vans das 20 minuten
nicht und so hat nicht so viel wert wie
fixiert und oder das blick aber ich bin
mir gar nicht so sicher bergab geht in
sachen die informationsstand vor der
öffentlichkeit
[Musik]
gerade gemüse
ja
die banken vorschlagen
na ja ich nehme täglich vorsatz weniger
in der zukunft sondern hat dass er mich
nicht erforscht machen und bist doch ein
stoß und moment ist das ist was eine
positive figur und immer noch ein
wechsel kann
logan vorsatz ich glaube du bist jetzt
oder sich die idee von peter sloterdijk
sehr gut mit der radikal sparen ich die
idee dass man sagt danke und schule
unterrichtet und über sich selber aus
erwacht und irgendwie immer noch ein
bisschen böse sehen dass die jungen ist
das schön aber ich muss sagen ich bin
zwar nahm die familie jahr mit nur drei
cluster vorsatz ich möchte ja sondern
langen und dankbar für das wohl ihrer
sache mit dem mit dem moment sowieso das
indeca oft gefühl ich kann nicht weg
klagt funktioniert habe ich von meiner
tag wenn ich mir halt nicht erlaubter
nicht press 17 und da ich bin ärgert
wenn man mit tierisches glückliches
erfülltes euro zahlt das irgendwie von
mir eben und schlüssel so einfach
stöhnte aber es ist aber schwierig und
das glück des lebens machte das team
aber so ein philosophischer evergreen
ist und hätte sandige 2010 bezahlt ganz
große rolle gespielt und immer wieder
von neuem für mich ist das größte glück
in meinem leben wenn ich eine aufgabe
habe die all meine fähigkeiten in
anspruch nimmt
all meine stärken
meine ganze konzentration das gelungene
leben ist für mich ein leben in dem wir
selbst bestimmt unsere projekte leben
die sinnvoll sind und in dem wir dazu
noch glücklich sind
es ist ein großartiges gefühl wenn sie
ein neues phänomen entdeckt haben und
sie es als erster mensch sehen
das ist schon etwas besonderes die
zufriedenheit im leben ist bei vielen
menschen eine kurve das heißt in ihr mal
dass sie wahrscheinlich gerade hier ist
aber es wird besser
dieses jahr 50 statistisch das nennt
sich sozusagen diese der tiefpunkt ist
die rushhour des lebens sie sind gerade
dabei karriere zu machen
sie haben eine junge familie sie haben
1000 dinge an die an ihnen zerren
und da ist man vorher freier und danach
auch wieder unglück ist immer ein kurzes
glück
man muss wird dein glück etwas anfangen
das glück ist im großen ganzen etwas was
ich herbeisehne wenn ich es nicht habe
wenn ich ganz bei der sache bin dann bin
ich ein mensch der nicht mehr nach dem
glück fragt was heißt glück erlebt man
nie sondern man vermisst das ja richtig
also das glück findet in jeder phase
unseres daseins statt wenn wir uns nicht
mehr fragen sind wir glücklich oder
nicht das passende leben ist das auch
das sinnvolle leben ja weil wir mit
allen phasen nach streben aber man
sollte das nicht das ziel ansehen
sondern aus wie wenn ein angriff martin
simons graviert nachher so kommt er wie
so berührt mich den und ich bin dann so
wirklich durch glückshormone durch
strömt das mein gehirn nur noch 80 super
ich habe meine damen und herren sind
schon an diesem jahresrückblick und
erwarte dies wieder interessante
gespräche und sandige unter anderem bin
ich im januar an bürger webforum frage
wer hat eigentlich gemacht der digital
rad und barbara ist in irland unterwegs
[Musik]
die
können
[Musik]
ok
mit dem break südstadt natürlich irland
wird eine zerreißprobe unterscheiden von
gründen warum ich auf die insel gereist
und natürlich interessiere mich freuen
die philosophische frage wo nicht auch
eine diskutieren unter anderem zum
beispiel wenn gehört eigentlich das land
und dafür benötigen wir einfach sagen
mehreren unabhängigkeit und natürlich
werden wir in irland auch über serie
game of thrones und könnte mir dieser
hype nach vordere fernsehserie wo ja
ganze 3 j als auch in irland befindet
jörg stuke kurz und macht vor der spruch
ich heute mit dem philosoph übel und
jetzt grad zeigt mir dass viele
künstlerin käthe kollwitz ja und jetzt
wünschen wir ihnen allen einen guten
rutsch und das kurz 2008 und als auch
gar nicht zu
[Musik]